If Impractical Jokers isn't your thing, Impractical
Jokers: The Movie isn't going to change your
mind.
If you dig the show's ridiculous sense of
humor, though, you'll like the movie, too.
No, it's not perfect but then again, what
is?
Unsurprisingly, the best thing about Impractical
Jokers: The Movie is also the best thing about
Impractical Jokers the television show: It
has a setup that works.
The movie's heart is the hidden-camera pranks,
just like the series.
Typically, these all use the same format.
Members of the cast are put into fairly mundane
situations for example, they need to flag
down help when their car breaks down on the
highway while their comrades watch from afar.
The Joker or Jokers in the hot seat are wearing
earpieces, and have to do whatever the others
tell them.
If you've seen the show, you know exactly
what to expect.
"Joe, just open-mouth sneeze on the wall."
If a Joker refuses to follow directions or
can't accomplish his goal, he gets a thumbs
down.
Whoever has the most thumbs-downs at the end
loses.
The movie works the same way.
It's just longer.
Sal, Q, Joe, and Murr are all extremely talented
improvisers, and easily come up with new ways
to torture their friends and spin their team
members' outrageous demands into comedy gold.
So what if we've seen it before?
Like they say, if it's not broken, don't fix
it.
"Yeah that's solid, that's good.
That's a for-suresky."
At this point, there are over 200 episodes
of the show, plus more than 30 TV specials.
That's a lot of Impractical Jokers, and while
the movie doesn't reference it all, it does
the best it can.
One gag plays on Sal's well-established fear
of cats.
Another recalls a bit from all the way back
in season two when Q had to teach his parents
sex ed.
If you've seen every episode of Impractical
Jokers, these callbacks should delight you.
"Oh, God that looks like it's, it was…"
"Oh, it's meowing"
On the other hand, if you're new to the show,
your mileage will probably vary.
The movie catches newbies up on what they
need to know, but a few punchlines don't really
land unless you've been following the gang
the whole time.
Impractical Jokers is a funny show, but it's
a modest one.
A lot of the action takes place in shopping
malls and city parks.
The challenges are simple, and on average
the punishments are pretty low key.
"Three, two, one, shhh..."
Not so in the movie.
While the film still relies on the charm and
talent of its cast for its humor, the bigger
budget and extra scope gives the group room
to go a little bit bigger.
It's hard to imagine Jaden Smith stopping
by to help with one of the pranks in the show.
The guys could've easily made a bigger, more
extravagant episode of the TV series and called
it a movie.
Instead, they decided to give the film an
actual story.
It's not clear why.
The film opens when the Jokers were still
in high school, and chronicles their mishaps
at a Paula Abdul concert gone wrong.
In the present day, the quartet get the opportunity
to redeem themselves when Abdul recognizes
them at a Red Lobster and invites them to
a party she's throwing in Miami.
There's just one problem:
"She sent three tickets!"
And so, as the Jokers travel from Long Island
to Florida, they compete in a series of prank
battles to see who gets left out.
Unfortunately, the pre-scripted plot scenes
drag everything to a halt.
Joe, Q, Sal, and Murr are funny guys, but
they're not great actors and none of the jokes
really hit there's a reason their sketch comedy
spinoff didn't even finish its six-episode
run, after all.
Impractical Jokers doesn't need to explain
why these guys are playing pranks.
It's just what they do.
Even worse, the story doesn't really lead
to anything, either.
It's mostly there to fill time, and it feels
completely unnecessary.
"What advice would you give filmmakers starting
out in order to help them to avoid the pitfalls
that you clearly fell into."
Impractical Jokers is uncomfortable, but it's
never cruel.
While Jackass is about inflicting pain and
Borat goes out of its way to make its targets
look like idiots, Impractical Jokers' only
real victims are the Jokers themselves.
Regular civilians might suffer minor inconveniences,
but the final joke is always on Joe, Sal,
Murr, and Q.
In the movie, the Jokers often decide it's
better to lose a challenge than put unsuspecting
civilians in awkward situations.
Instead of robbing Impractical Jokers of its
edge, the compassionate approach actually
makes the movie funnier.
Impractical Jokers isn't just a prank show.
It's a competition.
While the ultimate goal might be making the
audience laugh, each member of the cast spends
every episode doing his best to win the challenge
at hand.
After all, if you fail, you'll get turned
into a human pinata, forced to face down a
crowd of angry Bingo players, or worse.
"When I tell you to you're gonna take a deep
breath, alright?
And… deep breath.”
“Motherf----"
Those punishments were all real.
The one in the Movie isn't.
Missing out on a fake party isn't exactly
the same as being strapped to a table while
tarantulas walk all over you, and the film
suffers for it.
The consequences aren't real, so there's no
reason to care.
The movie has "punishments," of course, and
they're some of the best parts of the film,
but they don't work the same way they do on
the show.
On TV, the punishments are consequences for
failure.
In the movie, they're random asides that pop
up as the Jokers travel across the country.
That doesn't make them any less funny, but
it does make the movie even less exciting
than an episode of television.
Joe, Q, Sal, and Murr literally grew up together,
and their close bond comes through onscreen.
They know exactly how to push each other's'
buttons a skill that comes in pretty handy
when you're trying to put your buddy through
hell.
But they have an easy camaraderie that lends
itself well to comedy.
In a way, that's what makes Impractical Jokers'
pre-scripted scenes so jarring.
One of the things that makes Impractical Jokers
special is that the Jokers are clearly real
people.
The film's story segments, however, transform
all of them into cartoon characters.
That really doesn't work.
The movie is at its best when their real-life
bond is on full display.
Impractical Jokers is a short movie.
It clocks in at just over an hour and a half,
and most of it breezes right by.
Near the end of the film, however, things
begin to drag.
You're waiting for one big, final laugh that
never comes.
"Hell naw, to the naw naw naw.
I'm so sorry."
Again, it's not that big of a deal.
The rest of the movie is fun and likable,
and you'll leave the theater having had a
good time.
Still, something as good as Impractical Jokers:
The Movie deserves a real climax.
Or at least a little broccoli time.
"Get out!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.